[Music]
foreign
politano here for judging Freedom today
is Thursday October 20th
2022. it's a little after five o'clock
on the east coast of the United States
uh Our Guest today who is no stranger to
the judging Freedom audience who comes
to us from the west coast of the United
States is Dr Joel Wallach a naturopathic
physician who has partnered as you may
know with uh judging freedom to form
judging Health which is the website that
you can reach and access for nearly all
of your health care nutrition based
needs Dr wallet we'll talk a little bit
about a little bit more about this in a
moment but today first of all Dr Wallach
it's been about two weeks so I feel a
little empty without you but welcome
back to judging Freedom well thank you
sir it's an honor to be with you
uh thank you today
um I think you're going to talk about
joint Replacements that's correct now I
have to tell you that I understand you
to be and I know personally that you are
because you've advised me and a lot of
other people that I know and and think
highly of a naturopathic physician who
has helped a lot of people including me
to help the body to heal itself by the
ingestion of minerals ordinarily today
missing in our diet but what is a
naturopathic physician do with the need
for a joint replacement
well it's a great question judge and I
really appreciate your wisdom because
it's um highly improbable okay
but it goes back to I played a lot of
sports when I was a kid I wrestled I
played football I was only 110 pounds I
played on the offensive and defensive
line uh in in football I wrestled at 110
pounds
lettered in both Sports and so but I was
always seeing people with injuries and
stuff I never had the problems because I
had um when I was nine years old I had
a very very terrible
um let's see here uh level of um uh
behavioral problems okay and they're
going to institutionalize me and I
didn't want that to happen so I started
eating animal food with vitamins and
minerals in it it has an option to going
into these various um places as nine
years old and um uh
in three days time I cured myself it
freaked all the doctors out what did you
do what drugs are you taking well sir
I'm just I'm only nine years old I
didn't take any drugs I didn't tell them
what I did but they couldn't put me they
couldn't put me in in the um
lock up because I didn't have the
problems anymore so I realized when I
was nine years old the doctors didn't
know everything about health and that
there was room for people like myself
and so at first I went on to veterinary
school because we lived on a farm uh and
I got a degree in air I got a degree in
veterinary medicine
and
um I was working
um with
um uh let's see here Marlon Perkins an
old Mutual Omaha Kingdom show and I'm
treating people who had arthritis and
osteoporosis
and to make long story short
um
uh
I I came up with these products and they
fired me okay so I had to go back to
school and do something so I became a
nature at the doctor so I could see
human patients
and so my first products were always
named after animals my pig arthritis
formula my pig heart pack and all that
kind of stuff because I wanted people to
know I'm a veterinarian I'm not a
physician but I went back to school and
became a Nature Valley doctor and became
a naturopathic physician
and um that was in um well if I came to
you if I came to you with a joint that
needed to be replaced let's say my knee
from a high school football injury I did
have a high school football injury my
knee doesn't have to be replaced and as
you know from our conversations I work
out three times a week with a trainer
and the knee is in great shape but let's
say my knee needed to be replaced it was
just getting worse and worse and worse
what would you advise okay well we're
going to rebuild your knee okay the
beautiful thing that God did was make us
in such a way that we could be rebuilt
and um
my first my first patient
um from my
um a healthy Bone and Joint pack was
Theo Ratliff he was a 24 year old you
may remember the name Theo Ratliff he
was a 24 year old
um uh All-American basketball player
from
um let's see here Atlanta Georgia
Georgia Tech and he
um uh had the cartilage wore off of both
his knees cartilage came off his left
hip and he fractured his wrist on his
right shooting arm so he took away his
contract he was playing for the the um
uh Atlanta Hawks they took away his 35
million dollar contract when he was 24
years old and Pastor Creflo Dollar
introduced me to him and says can you do
anything for him I said yes sir I'm
going to give him a nutritional program
and a diet which we did and in 90 days I
had regrown his knees his hip his wrist
he came back he played for 11 years your
honor he played 11 years made a hundred
million dollars in contracts for playing
professional basketball right so so tell
me what was regrown not the bone oh yes
sir the bone the cartilage the ligaments
the tendons the connective tissue
um everything I was part of the skeletal
system which is very complex system
because it's not just bone it's bone and
cartilage and connective tissue and
ligaments and so forth and so what did
you what did you give him that
stimulated and produced this regrowth
well I've stimulated the growth but I
also gave them all the raw materials
that were necessary for the bones to
regrow and to repair themselves the good
lord gave us the ability to repair
ourselves but we do need stuff to do it
now unfortunately nutritional minerals
do not occur in a uniform blanket around
the crust of the earth they occur in
veins like gold and silver also we had
easy access to these minerals
through wood ashes and coal ashes up
until three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 when Thomas
Edison pulled the switch and turned on
the electricity and everybody ran to
electricity we didn't have any more wood
ashes or any more coal ash anymore we
wrote a best-selling book called Hell's
Kitchen
um named after the terrible District in
New York City where everything goes
wrong
and so Hell's Kitchen it tells the story
of the transition from thousands of
years of using wood ashes as a
fertilizer in our garden and the carrots
and the onions and tomatoes and potatoes
and stuff would soak up right we get the
minerals I'm interested in this this
basketball player this professional
athlete yeah
you persuaded him
not to have surgery not to have any
joint replacement to accept your
minerals and supplements and after 90
days whatever was ailing him was cured
and he went back and played for the
Atlanta Hawks for another 11 years so I
have that right that's correct
and these supplements are the same ones
that are available on your website today
that is correct okay how would one know
uh what supplements to take or stated
differently Dr Wallach how would one
know if one needs to have
bone or cartilage or uh soft tissue
regrown
okay well the doctor would tell them
that look we've got to do surgery we're
going to have to amputate your leg give
you an artificial leg we're going to
give you an artificial hip we're going
to give you an artificial knee all that
kind of stuff and they come to me
because they don't want all that
artificial stuff now this started again
in 1982 and the Theo ratlas was my first
one so I had to come up with a program
for healing bones and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and cartilage and
stuff like that which we did well we
have 21 best-selling books uh Hell's
Kitchen is that transition okay from
wood and Kohl's fuel we're getting
minerals that way through the ashes
night the ashes were 90 minerals only
three percent carbon okay and then
um
epigenetics which is a summary of my
thesis which is in the Smithsonian
Institute of the National Treasure
because I found out that there are no
gently transferences there are no
autoimmune diseases they're all
nutritional deficiencies so my thesis is
in the Smithsonian Institute of national
tree let me let me interrupt you for a
minute
rmds trained in nutrition are they
trained to recognize nutritional
deficiencies no sir
see they don't learn that in medical
school because what happens is somebody
comes in with swollen knee they take an
x-ray they say oh you have arthritis in
your knee
okay that's all they know uh Grandma
before that for thousands of years when
kids had because right now we have 300
000 Kids In America under age 16 with
arthritis when you when kids have
arthritis and their knees and their
shoulders and their hips and knees and
and back and wrists and shoulders and
elbows and ankles and so forth grandma
says oh you have Growing Pains
you have growing pains and you'll
outgrow this as you get older it might
be because as they got older they would
start eating bone broth and eating the
ends off of Bones and things that they
didn't do when they were a kid okay and
so they could actually get rid of the
osteoporosis and arthritis at that time
and I don't remember I don't remember
what I was complaining about
but and I haven't heard this phrase and
65 years but I remember now my
grandmother and even my mother saying
you're having growing pains
yeah because you had pains in your ankle
your knees your hips your back your
shoulders your neck right yeah and was
it was it a nutritional deficiency which
I eventually overcame well you your body
adapted to it because you're eating an
adult diet as opposed to a kid's diet
and you know kids are probably eating
oatmeal for breakfast so does it damage
your intestines you couldn't absorb
nutrition
and um people you can't tell from a
blood test you have to get a hair
analysis and so he came up with this
book it's called a rare Earths or bin
cures uh go to chapter 10 11 page 272
tells you how to collect the hair where
to ship it don't put don't forget to put
the check in there because the lab won't
run the test it'll tell you uh where
your nutritional minerals are at in
levels are they good are they bad are
they deficient and so forth and they
also go into poisonous minerals like
lead and mercury and that kind of thing
and so that book is very useful and so
um we have standard programs now we've
developed these standard programs and
they go all over the world athletes of
every sport
probably
um I probably have
I don't know how many million athletes
of all ages all over the world who use
my programs because they work they
rebuild the knees and the hips and the
the shoulders and the wrists and the
ankles and the backs and the necks and
all this kind of stuff saying go back
and play and get their money okay and um
the cost uh to the general public is
very high because they're listening to
their grandmother oh listen to your
doctor go to your doctor and so they go
to the doctor the doctor says oh
um you have osteoporosis and um we're
going to have to do some surgery on you
and blah blah blah blah and
you're going to be on these medications
forever
okay I'm an insurance page and so the
doctor doesn't feel guilty about it and
the patient doesn't mind so much because
insurance is paying for for the uh pain
relief again we spend 626.8 billion
dollars a year just to treat the
symptoms of arthritis in America just to
treat the symptoms not to prevent it or
cure it
626.8 billion dollars annually okay it's
totally wasted money I can eliminate
that in 90 days if everybody would do
what I would say and then osteoporosis
we spend 6.5 trillion dollars a year
just to treat symptoms of osteoporosis
in the U.S
6.5 trillion dollars are spent to treat
osteoporosis in the United States the
United States Canada and the EU those
three countries because we all have the
same background what is uh what is
osteoporosis is that a form of arthritis
uh well it is yeah arthritis is uh
osteoporosis of the joints
okay osteoporosis is of the long part of
the bone okay that's where people get no
I was just walking down the stairs my I
broke my my femur and my thigh bone
broke okay and that's where doctors want
to give them a artificial leg take their
you know amputate their leg give an
artificial limb and all that kind of
stuff yeah there's no sense even mess
with these bones are falling apart we'll
just give you an artificial leg and take
their amputate them and so forth but 6.5
trillion
annually to treat osteoporosis in the
United States Canada and the EU and then
it's 626.8 billion dollars a year just
to treat the symptoms of osteoporosis
excuse me arthritis in America that's
just America 626.8 billion
okay plus one-third of that 6.5 trillion
so it's 2.2 trillion okay so let's say I
go let's say I go to judginghealth.com
okay and I'm looking for something to
address a pain in my wrist
and I find the product what is in that
product okay that will address the
underlying issue of arthritis in the
wrist okay it's not a product okay
that's kind of a misthinking on terms of
the doctor oh I'm going to give you this
painkiller they give them my own and the
patient's happy because the pain is gone
but the disease keeps going and getting
worse and worse worse then they finally
get to the point where they're going to
amputate them and give them a false limb
or something like that
but
basically as a veterinarian I learned a
long time ago okay and in agricultural
school I learned a long time ago and as
a pathologist
25 million in Grants
um
my thesis is in the Smithsonian
institute's National Treasure because I
showed
what causes all these diseases my thesis
sold for 25 000 each
now the book that is a kind of a summary
of The Thesis is this one it sells for
only 25 not 25
000 is 25 but the thesis you can go to
any
um of the Smithsonian Institute
libraries and say I want to see Dr
Wong's book disease of exotic animals
and they send a guard with you because
people want to steal the book so they
always send the guard with them so they
don't pick up the book and put them in
their purse or the briefcase and walk
out with them
so
um basically what we did we come up with
what we call the healthy brain and heart
pack
okay really deals with every tissue of
the body but we couldn't list every
tissue in the body on the on the label
it didn't label wasn't big enough so we
called the healthy brain and heart pack
and the health brain and heart pack
has
215 nutrients in it 90 of which
everybody including medical doctors
agree are essential nutrients okay the
others were working on getting them to
be considered essential nutrients but
anyway I held the brain and heart fact
uh one per 100 pounds of body weight per
month then the MSM this actually regrows
cartilage and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue including your heart
valves and walls of arteries and veins
what is it what's what's what are the
minerals that are in the
msmiths there's 66 zero minerals wow
okay there's 60 of them but we have
different
um which I say we add more of some of
those minerals
um
continuous disease you have for instance
diabetes is a simple nutritional
deficiency it's not a genetic disease or
autoimmune disease in any way shape or
form type 2 diabetes which makes up 98
of diabetes is totally a nutritional
deficiency disease of minerals so we
came up with what we call the healthy
blood sugar pack for that and then I
don't care if you've had type 2 diabetes
for 45 years and two to six weeks it's
gone
that's what makes us different that's
why people come to us that's why all
these professional athletes come to us
that's why these Olympic Games we get
into Olympic athletes from all over the
world come
um by the hundreds every month for us
we are all uh brainwashed I suppose to a
certain extent by the medical community
I could name ten friends
who are uh let's say between the age 65
and age 80.
who've had joint Replacements knee or
hip they're so totally unnecessary here
in northern New Jersey there are doctors
who do nothing but it you look at their
websites and they say I've done ten
thousand I've done 15 000 of them could
it be true that the vast majority of
these were not necessary and could have
been addressed by nutritional deficiency
or by a means of addressing nutritional
deficiency
your honor you're a genius you're
exactly right you picked it out right
away
all right
that's right 99 of the time when people
have arthritis osteoporosis
um and they have all these various
things going on with their bones and
ligaments and tendons connective tissue
they do not need surgery and joint
replacement surgeries and limb
replacement surgeries and all that kind
of stuff no no no I always say give me
90 days before you go to that direction
give me 90 days okay you've been
suffering for years so what's 90 days
give me 90 days do exactly as I say
and I don't charge anything for my cost
you'll pay wholesale prices for the
products I take nothing for my cost okay
and so
um you know so you it's like you're
getting my my services for free
okay and so it's one of those things
where I did it that way so there would
be no reason for people not to do this
because I want to see as many positives
as we could
Dr Wallach you uh never stop amazing us
we'll come up with a topic for uh next
week this has been a fascinating
fascinating 20 minutes with you thank
you very much for joining us thank you
again well God bless you your honor God
bless you sir
okay there it is judginghealth.com uh
judgment politano for judging health and
judging freedom
[Music]